digamos que voy a pintar una mano y
bueno voy a hacer mi mejor esfuerzo
digamos que ahí está el pulgar de esta
mano ok y ahora va el dedo índice el
dedo medio digamos el dedo anular y
finalmente el dedo más chiquito de la
mano ahí está una mano izquierda digamos
ok más o menos fue mi mejor esfuerzo y
ahora vamos a decir que tengo aquí un
espejo de esta línea punteada es un
espejo y voy a pintar la reflexión que
hay en este espejo de esta mano es decir
qué pasaría si estuviéramos viendo la
mano desde o bueno sobre el espejo y
aquí tendremos nuestro pulgar el dedo
índice
los medios
y ahí tendríamos el dedo anular y
finalmente el dedo pequeño entonces este
es más o menos un intento de una
reflexión de esta mano ok pero yo creo
que entienden la idea
y realmente el punto que quiero que
abarcamos con esta idea de la mano es
que a lo mejor yo podría intentar rotar
esta mano digamos 180 grados o podría
trasladarlo no no importa de qué forma
el punto es que no va a haber una forma
posible en la que yo pueda sobreponer
esta mano sobre esta otra y que queden
justamente en palmas verdad a lo mejor
uno podría intentar rotar esta mano de
tal suerte que el pulgar que los
pulgares queden encima dos verdad pero
como esta es una mano izquierda seguiría
hacia acá verdad entonces realmente no
tenemos forma alguna de sobreponer esta
mano azul que es la digamos la mano
izquierda sobre su reflexión ya esto es
justamente a lo que le llamamos una
propiedad que irá al verdad entonces
déjenme déjenme escribirlo así
justamente cuando no se puede
cuando no se puede sobreponer aunque y
sobreponer digamos ya sea con traslación
es o quizás con rotaciones o algunos
movimientos digamos rígidos entonces si
no se puede sobreponer sobre su imagen
reflejada y aquí por ejemplo estamos
pensando en su imagen en el espejo
verdad su imagen reflejada justamente
cuando se tiene esta propiedad de que no
lo podemos sobreponer sobre su imagen
reflejada es justamente lo que decimos
que es tirar verdad ok
y justamente tiene mucho sentido porque
justamente kieran es bueno esto proviene
de la palabra en griego para referirnos
a mano aunque entonces proviene de la
palabra griega para referirnos a mano
entonces y esta definición no sólo no
solo se aplica cuando estemos hablando
de química o de matemáticas supongo
también por ejemplo para amarnos en
general así que podemos extender esta
definición a la química justamente
porque de eso estamos trabajando en esta
serie de vídeos y aquí hay dos conceptos
muy importantes cuando trabajamos en
química el primero de ellos son las
moléculas quirales
ahí está moléculas
tirarles aunque es digamos nuestro
primer concepto importante en química y
también tenemos los centros quirales o
que quizás deberían llamarles átomos y
darles muy bien digamos que estos son
los átomos virales
atom hospitales o centros finales y
literalmente las moléculas quirales son
aquellas que no se pueden superponer
sobre su imagen reflejada ok no es bueno
déjenme escribirlo así justamente
lo importante es que no se pueden
superponer
superponer o sobreponer
entonces no se pueden superponer o
sobreponer de su super por
sobre su imagen reflejada sobre su
imagen reflejada muy bien
sobre su imagen
reflejada y ahí lo tienen y para los
átomos quirales se tiene esencialmente
lo mismo pero cuando buscamos digamos
átomos tirarles dentro de una molécula
la mejor forma de ubicarlos es
reconociendo que estos en general y
quizás debería decir usualmente son son
carbonos especialmente cuando estamos
trabajando en química orgánica pero
podrían ser fósforos o por ejemplo
azufre por usualmente son carbonos
unidos a cuatro grupos distintos
entonces vamos a vamos a anotar esos son
usualmente
son carbonos son carbonos unidos
unidos a cuatro grupos y esto es lo más
importante a cuatro grupos diferentes
muy bien estos pensados dentro de una
molécula y sólo para ejemplificar una
molécula que contiene un átomo quiral un
carbono que irá vamos a pensar en un
ejemplo digamos que aquí tenemos nuestro
carbono tenemos un carbono y este deberá
tener cuatro enlaces verdad digamos que
en el primer enlace uno que esté
saltando justamente la pantalla de la
hoja sea nosotros podría ser un grupo
metilo un ch tres y digamos que justo
sobre la misma hoja se encuentra un
bromo no sé a lo mejor hacia arriba está
saltando digamos un flúor un átomo de
flúor y por atrás se encuentra un átomo
de hidrógeno verdad entonces pensemos
cuál sería su imagen reflejada entonces
ponemos un espejo
ahí está el espejo tendremos que poner
nuevamente nuestro carbono
y ahora este s h3 este grupo metilo se
encuentran nuevamente saltando hacia el
frente hacia nosotros pero del lado
derecho verdad entonces ahí tenemos
nuestro grupo metilo del lado izquierdo
ahora se encuentra nuestro bromo y por
atrás nuevamente se encuentra el
hidrógeno y hacia arriba el átomo de
flúor entonces este digamos su imagen
reflejada y podemos preguntarnos ahora
por qué esta molécula espiral bueno en
realidad es como un reto de
visualización porque realmente no
importa como rotemos esta esta esta
molécula digamos que a lo mejor
podríamos intentar rotarla en este
sentido de tal suerte que a lo mejor
este bromo al rotarlo llegue a pasar a
esta posición verdad pero entonces qué
es lo que va a pasar que el bromo llega
a la posición del del
o bueno quizás sería mejor visualizarlo
respecto al grupo metilo por ejemplo si
empalmamos los grupos metilo que es lo
que va a ocurrir este digamos se movió a
la posición justamente que se encuentra
del lado derecho y qué ocurre con los
otros pues entonces el hidrógeno ocupa
la posición del grupo metilo mientras
que el bromo ocupa la posición del
hidrógeno y si nos damos cuenta en
realidad aquí si si si se pudieran
empalmar aquí debería haber un hidrógeno
y aquí un bromo pero no es cierto están
justamente al revés entonces realmente
no importa como rotemos estas dos
moléculas no se pueden empalmar y es por
eso que esta molécula es una molécula
quiral y por supuesto tendremos que
entonces el carbono es un centro que ir
al vamos a ponerlo así es un centro
tirar o un átomo que ir al justamente
porque está unido a cuatro grupos
diferentes y a veces justamente también
se le conoce como estéreo centro que es
un término un poco más general para
cualquier punto en una molécula que es
asimétrico respecto a los distintos
grupos a los cuales está unido
estos especialmente cuando estamos en un
curso introductorio de química orgánica
tenderán a ser carbonos que están unidos
a cuatro grupos distintos verdad y lo
que quiero digamos
remarcar es que no son cuatro átomos
diferentes en realidad podríamos haber
tenido un grupo metilo y a lo mejor acá
un grupo propio y lo que a lo mejor
coinciden en en ciertos átomos el punto
importante es que sean cuatro grupos
diferentes verdad para que podamos decir
que es una molécula quiral y que por lo
tanto este sería un centro que irá lo un
átomo quiral ahora en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a hacer un montón de ejemplos
vamos a ver algunas moléculas que vamos
a tratar de identificar cuáles son los
carbonos quirales y tratar de ver cuando
la molécula en sí misma es una molécula
quiral